hey what is up guys my name is jonah
welcome to episode 22 of 3d game
programming in java all right
so so uh let's check out what we've got
um all right so we've got like this
thing
right and the there's a few problems
first of all we can't see it from well
everywhere
and the other problem is that well
there's only one thing it's really
boring now
i made you guys sort of like a deal last
time i i said that if we
if we could reach uh 200 likes
then what i would do was show you guys
how to basically make
a level all right and more specifically
because i didn't want to waste time
actually
you know making a level like manually i
thought you know let's just make a
random
like not really level more like a random
wall generator
which would basically just place random
like walls
everywhere um obviously not like
completely random otherwise that
wouldn't really work that'd just be
basically random chunks of blue texture
everywhere
but uh but you know but it would look
like a room
but the walls and like the ma it's like
a kind of like kind of like a maze you
know
like a randomly generated maze so that
every time you close this and you run it
again
they'll be it'll be different um to an
extent obviously there's not going to be
one billion possibilities
there's probably going to be about maybe
100 200
1 000 i don't know i haven't actually
calculated how many possibilities there
will be but yeah
so that that was if we re if we would
reach 200 likes
now um fortunately for you guys
we uh we did 215 likes and uh zero
dislikes which is
awesome so i am going to have to
do the uh the random level generator
this episode so that is what we're going
to do
okay um this episode and
you know i like now that i think about
it i've wasted basically two minutes
explaining you guys what we're gonna do
today whereas you could have probably
read it from the title of the video
so i realized that now it's a little bit
too late but uh
yeah but the point is random level
generator
not really i i really don't want to call
it a level generator because it's not
like all we've got is walls
so a random wall generator is what's
going to happen
today all right so there's a few there's
a few things
we need to do for that first of all we
need to set up like a system in which we
can actually
create levels or blocks or tiles i don't
know whatever you guys want to call them
um and that's that's kind of simple okay
first thing we're going to do is
actually let's uh
okay we'll go into the game class and uh
and we'll actually okay we'll make a new
we'll make a new class and i'm just
gonna straight ahead
go public we'll call it level level
level all right
and let's just create the class from
here because i'm lazy we're not going to
import it make sure
you don't import the java level we're
going to create a new class called level
let's put it into its own uh package or
folder called level
uh because there's going to be like a
whole different types of levels and
stuff like that that we'll create
so yeah and hit finish all right so now
we've got a new class
uh called level all right so now let's
start
sort of playing around with that now i
think that
okay what i'll probably do is i'll call
these
they're called like technically you'd
call them walls because
oh wow holy crap what's going on
all right here we go that was weird um
must be like a problem with clipping or
something seems fine though
it only happens sometimes anyway so uh
we sort of want to be generating these
walls but i want to sort of allow align
them into
arrange them into like actual walls so
i'm going to call them um
i'm going to call them blocks all right
so we need to basically uh
make a class called uh an array class
called block um so that's what i'm going
to do now so public block make sure you
have the uh
the two square brackets uh
blocks all right and again i'm i'm just
being lazy again instead of actually
going you know right click or file new
class i'm just basically typing it like
that that's what i do when i don't
make tutorials you know it's easy that
way um and we'll put into level again
and we'll hit finish and
uh yeah all right one thing i want to
just say quickly
is um i'm sorry if i'm non-enthusiastic
or
sort of slow or tired i've had a long
day
you guys can say this 8 51 p.m it's kind
of late um
so yeah i'm sorry if i'm you know tired
or whatever
i'm just bear with me i'll probably get
more excited
as this actually goes along all right so
we want to make a constructor for this
level class now
i'm sure you guys know what a
constructor is uh it'll take two
parameters with night
um and we'll actually set up quickly set
up two constants
so we'll call them final and that will
be the width and height
so what we need to do is actually
say at this point okay so we've made
this we've made two variables
and the reason we actually make the
variables okay
i'm really gonna explain this all right
hang on first of all
is there actually a problem here or is
this no there's actually no problem here
um okay so the reason that we've sort of
made
very like we've made two variables here
is because i'm going to make another
method here in a second
um and that'll be like a way of actually
uh
making like blocks all right um
of actually making the blocks and i want
to use
whatever we input here into
the other method right and to do that i
need to it's
okay we've done this before i haven't
actually explained this before
we okay we did this before where we
wanted to use
walking in another method so we wanted
to use it in
in um in floor and in render wall
right so we had to put it up here same
thing here you know
except it's it's their parameters that
we input
which is why we need to do the following
code we've actually done
exactly the same thing before okay
here it is up here and let's just
actually just put it like that might as
well um
all right that might make it easier to
i'd i
you can do that actually i'm not gonna
do that though because um i like to have
width and height
sort of separately so yeah it's up to
you um
uh they they'll actually have the exact
same effect obviously
i just sort of like distinct width and
height to be distinct you know if it's
something stupid like
xyz then you might as well just put it
onto the same line
and separate them by commas um but yeah
anyway
i've gone on for a long time so what we
need to do now is say all right well
let's assign whatever
parameter we put in here to be stored in
this global
variable that will be public and it'll
actually be visible throughout the
entire class not just this method
so this dot width
equals width and you guys can see if i
just
put my mouse over this thing it's going
to set with
equal to width and this dot
height equals
height right simple as that
and you can see that it's obviously gone
away because we've handled it
the the error has gone away i mean all
right um actually while we're at it
let's just make a block
uh we'll make a method public block
um
we'll call create or place
maybe i don't know uh index and
y and uh
i'm just wondering what we should do
first
let's actually uh okay first thing i'll
actually do is
let's uh we'll obviously have to return
something through this because we've
made a method out of this thing so we
need to return it
something obviously not null what we
actually want to return is
uh is blocks the uh the array that we
just made here
that's what we want to return so x just
x plus y times with
um same as always and uh we'll actually
we'll actually
deal with this in a second but i i don't
want to sort of focus on this too much i
actually want to deal with blocks first
so um there's sort of two
little things i want to deal with um the
first is we'll have a boolean
called solid and we'll set that equal to
false at the moment
so what a solid wall is it's going to be
a world that's actually like
filled okay we could call this like wall
exists or something i don't know i'm
just going to call it solid so
it's basically going to be like a solid
piece of texture or whatever um
basically like this is this is a this is
this thing is really annoying this is
what it is um
this would be like a solid wall this
would be like not that would be false
that would be true because there's
nothing here so it's false
and that's pretty much all we need here
one other thing we actually need though
is uh is
um
all right ah okay solid wall
and i'll set that equal to we'll have to
make a new class i'll just call it solid
block
all right so let's create the new class
i'm just gonna create a new class again
in level and all the solid block is
going to have
is basically all it's going to have is a
uh
a constructor which all the constructor
does
is set it equal to um
a solid block what do we call it solid
equals true so
i i meant did i mention it okay it
extends block so that's why
the variable solid is it's transferred
because it extends it right
so you guys know what extends mean means
i'm pretty sure extends means that
basically solid block is going to
inherit all the variables and methods
that block has
so if block had a method called public
uh public void i don't know
test if um if this had a method called
like
called that we could call them the
method basically like this
like we wouldn't actually have to um
oh sorry wait
what was wrong with that that body
what
that's weird anyway i didn't actually
make it properly but the point is that
uh you know we don't have to actually
create an object and then go
you know like block.solid equals true or
anything we can just go
solid equals true because it's this
variable is visible in this because this
extends block so this inherits solid
block inherits all the variables and
methods
and stuff like that of the thing that of
the class that it extends which in this
case is block
okay um so we've done that all right so
you guys know what constructions are
right like okay i'm not even i don't
know why i'm tired guys i'm sorry i just
feel like i need to explain everything i
do probably don't
um you guys will see what constructs the
meaning of construction basically
whenever we call this so whenever if if
we if we call
solid wall then solid wall is equal to a
new solid block
so solid block means that it's the solid
is equal to true because when we call
whenever we go
new solid block then it creates a solid
block with this
with these basically with these uh
parameters i don't want to call them
parameters but
with these uh um characteristics
okay solid equals true so uh whenever we
basically call a block of the type
solid wall again we could basically what
we could do is
go public static block non-solid wall or
something
equals new you know non-solid wall
and then what we would have and i'm just
proving a point here i'm not actually
going to do this
and we would make a new class and we'd
make a constructor for it again
it does extend block so public non-solid
wall
um solid equals false
and that will be it all right so that
when whenever we say
let's make a non-solid wall block type
get out here adobe reader whenever we
make a non-solid
wall type it's going to be non-solid
because
solid equals false whenever we make a
non-solid wall okay is that is that
clear
i hope it is because i'm going to delete
that class
okay all right
that's probably the first time i've
actually created a class to prove a
point but
yeah anyway all right so um
let's um that's that's looking good so
far i don't think we need to do anything
else let's go back to our level class
and where's our level class level class
and let's uh let's continue with this
all right so
what we want to do is basically make
sure that blocks we actually need to
initiate
instantiate that type uh and so we'll
make a new block out of it and again all
we'll do is
uh we'll we'll we'll make it a new block
with basically just width
uh times height because it only takes
one parameter
so width times height will be the the
answer
and um what i'll do basically is we need
to
we need to basically set up a rendering
system for blocks now or for the level
so uh let's just do the basic you know
our basic thing where
y equals zero y is less than height and
again again this is keep in mind that
this isn't going to render the entire
screen
this is going to render whatever we set
here in the parameters
so um so yeah and again
inside of this one you know we'll create
another one for x so that we're
rendering whatever
x times y is basically um and y equals
zero
as long as x is less than with
x plus plus all right
show show show um
i think what we'll do first of all is
actually
we'll make a block and we'll set it
equal to null so that basically block
at the moment is going to be no there's
no block at the moment and then
what i'll actually do is we'll actually
set up the random
number generator here the random level
generator here
all right so we've done this before
actually i want to take a drink of water
and what a bunch of cherries in front of
me so i'm going to grab a cherry as well
sorry guys i try to keep these
episodes you know casual so you guys
might see me eating cherries in the
future as well
anyway
okay so
basically what we use is something
called random
now when when
okay if i don't know how you guys think
of a random
like level generator but if you guys
actually say
all right i'm going to try and make a
random
level generator or whatever by myself
it doesn't have to be a level generator
but something random like you want to
generate something random
by myself how am i going to go about
that now it's very simple what you need
is something
to randomly generate numbers for you
and that's where the java random class
comes in random we'll call it random
obviously
equals new not mu this isn't pokemon
no mu no mu2 um random random equals new
random let's just import that i just
want control shift o to import by the
way um i might teach you guys some
shortcuts over the future but anyway
um and what random can do for us is
basically generate a
number all right within the within the
range of numbers
that we give it all right and then what
we can then say
is it's kind of like think of it as
minecraft right like i haven't i haven't
seen the minecraft source code so i
can't say how the
gen how the how it randomly generates
levels but i would imagine it being
something like
basically going ahead and saying you
know if
let's generate a random number between
one and five right
and this is for any this isn't just for
minecraft it's for any like random
generator random wall generating
whatever
you know let's pick a let's pick a
random number between one and five
if the numbers one do this if the
numbers two
do this if the numbers three do this or
whatever
okay um
it's really you know as simple as that
and obviously you could
have ranges of numbers so you could say
that if the random number we generate is
between
one and three then do this or
but but if it's between four and five do
this
or if it's between you know 605 and 890
do this so that's sort of how we're
going to approach this we're just going
to say
um if random dot
next int we only we only want to
generate integers because it gets sort
of
tricky with doubles um and there's no
requirement for it
so let's okay random.net it takes one
parameter
and it you don't have to take a
parameter but you can and that parameter
is going to be the amount of
like the limit of numbers it's going to
generate so all we want to do is we want
to generate
five numbers so we put the number four
because remember zero is one of them
so it's basically going to generate a
number between zero one two three and
four so it's between zero and four
it's gonna pick it's gonna pick a random
number every time we run this code
um and let's just say that if that is
equal to zero
then let's actually we'll we'll place a
solid block so
block equals new solid
block all right it's as simple as that
um
and obviously if the number is not equal
to zero if the random number isn't zero
then let's make that block just equal a
new block
in which case it'll just make it a uh
solid equals false it'll make it false
block it won't be
solid um all right and we'll fill the
array
with that so blocks x plus y
uh times width
equals block
if i can spell oh my goodness i can't
all right okay let me explain this code
real quick if you guys don't get it
um let me yeah okay i am recording good
all right um so what it's going to do is
it's going to pick up
pick a random number between 0 and 5
between zero and four
if that number happens to be zero it's
going to place a solid block there and
remember it's going to do this a lot of
times
this is in this is in two for loops so
this it's actually gonna do this
a lot of times it's not just gonna do it
once um
so it's gonna it's gonna on one of the
passes through the loops it's gonna
pick a number and if that number is zero
it's gonna be a solid block
so in other words our code at the moment
has a one
in five chance of actually rendering a
solid block
okay and if obviously the number is not
zero so if it's like
if it's basically if it's one two three
or four it's gonna
create just a blank block so it's not
going to make a wall
all right now we could have done
something like if random
dot next in four what we actually would
have done is is
actually made a int
random number
equals and we would set it equal to this
um and then we would say if random
number
i'm trying to get through this as fast
as i can if if random number
is greater than um
i don't know one but
it's less than like
um i don't know
five you wouldn't really put this like
this so you you'd put one
here hang on hang on i'm getting
confused now
would you do it like no yeah you do it
like this though technically
around if random number is
uh greater than five sorry greater than
um
one but less than five and you can
actually do that at the moment but
this is just basic mathematics you know
basically if random number is
you can't do that in java i know but but
i'm just i'm proving a point here
um if random number you know is less
than one greater than five to do this
you know
or if it's something else and do
something else okay so uh that's that's
how you would do it pretty much
but uh we're not gonna get into that now
and of course you could do that but
at the moment we're just gonna focus on
this i'm just yeah i'm just sort of
teaching you this stuff so you guys can
play around with this code don't feel
like you're constrained to
what i'm doing right now play around
with it you know
i could say greater than two here and
that would increase
increase the chances of actually
rendering a wall but we're not gonna get
go into that
right now all right anyway back to this
what time are we at probably
like 21 minutes you guys like long
tutorials though so i'm not gonna
rush but i have stuff to do so i will
probably will rush um
one more thing we'll we'll quickly do is
we'll set uh an if statement here that
basically just says um
if x is less than zero or y is less than
zero
so basically if it's um if it's
out of the screen if it's greater than
or equal to width
uh or and this isn't this isn't the
screen this is the
remember this is the um i'll tell you
guys in a sec
this is x and y so this is from the uh
the create thing that we call
um y is
uh greater than or equal to height we'll
just we'll just return
a return block dot solid wall
there we go awesome all right so i'll
show you guys how this works in a minute
uh first we actually need to go over to
our game.java class which is here
and we actually need to create that
level so
level equals new level and
let's just go ahead and put 2020 for the
parameters we'll see what that does
because i don't know yet um so yeah all
right so now let's
go on to actually well you know creating
the
the walls um now for this
i'm actually gonna sort of create those
walls in the uh
right in the render 3d class all right
um let's just
i'm not going to create them here just
for just for sort of i'll move them
here eventually but let's just comment
out this entire
line of code this entire like
four lines of code so that when we run
now we'll just get
we won't get any walls all right cool
let's start randomly generating them now
all right so let's go back into render
3d and uh we'll actually
make sure that it's in like a thing that
we run so in the floor thing and let me
just hit the
i want to put my like my typie thing my
basically my keyboard like
cursor thing i don't know what i don't
know i don't know what you call it but
the type thing
uh just after the bracket that opens up
this class
and it'll sort of put a box around it'll
highlight basically the one
the the accompanying end brackets so i
know that
this is the last bracket so i'm going to
use it it's kind of more useful for
where you've got three brackets here
obviously
that is the last the last bracket of
that class but right before
that the end of that class make sure you
don't put it into a
into the for loop okay that's important
because uh it won't look good so let's
first of all
create a uh a level
and we'll we won't set it equal to new
level all right we've already initiated
the
level type so we'll just use the one
that's already been initiated in game
instantiated in game whatever um so
game dot level all right so level
level equals gamma level we need to
import level again make sure you import
the one
that's in your package not in java's
important all right um
then we basically need to also specify a
size now
the size is basically going to be like
the size of our level like
from which point to which point is the
gonna is it going to randomly generate
walls
so it's like a block of land you know we
only want to generate walls in an area
that's i don't know like 20 by 20 meters
or whatever
so we'll set it equal to um just for now
we'll set it equal to like five
equals five um just for now we'll play
around with that number and you guys can
see what it does
all right so now we need to talk about
actually making a for loop that will
render this stuff for us so if we take a
look at render wall because render wall
is what we've been using
we've got five parameters here that we
need to fulfill all right but mainly
we've got
two sort of groups okay don't worry
about height for now because we'll uh
we'll play
we'll play around with that later we
obviously don't want to randomly
generate height at the moment um
so we've got left we've got right we've
got z distance
and uh z distance right so
let's sort of put the x blocks and x
block
is going to be these two basically into
x block
equals zero um no it's not going to
consider what am i done
it's going to equal size but we actually
have to go negative size
and as long as that x block is less than
or equal to size um
then let's just x block
uh plus plus all right and then inside
that we'll put another for loop
basically the same thing but for these
for these z blocks
right i'm gonna i'm gonna call them z
blocks because basically these have x's
in front of them they have zeros in
front of them it's pretty
self-explanatory uh and again we're
gonna set that equal to negative
size
um
um yeah we'll set them equal to negative
size
and let's uh let's set them equal to
let's as you know as long as it's less
than or equal to size
then we can uh continue doing it all
right
so yeah awesome um
all right cool so we need to make two
we need to make a few different blocks
right um we need to make a main block
so we'll just call it block and this
local our level
dot uh create so it's going to create
our block
and um we'll fill it in with x lock and
z block respectively and we need to make
two more instances of block
and there's going to be basically one
for the east side and basically one for
the south side so i'm just going to call
them east and south
so east is going to be equal to level
dot create
and what i'll do is i'll exactly the
same parameters
except i'll actually add one to this
now you guys might be like if you guys
are bright
and you understand what i mean what is
wrong with this
let's first of all import this
i can figure out what's wrong with this
um
how is it not applicable is that block
not an integer we just use it didn't we
why is up with this did i spell it right
yeah i did that is weird okay i'll get
back to that in a minute
um and you guys might be like you know
plus one like what's
there's actually like a somehow i
i don't know what caused that honestly
anyway
um i don't know i might watch back and
see what the hell i did
but um yeah so you know you guys might
be like okay well we're sort of dealing
with 0.50 shouldn't we add a 0.5 and we
should
but the problem is that at the moment we
sort of can't because we've said this
is equal to an int and because width and
height are sort of bound to integers i
don't want to really mess around with
rerouting them to doubles
um so we'll deal with one and then we'll
later divide that value by two when
necessary
and finally we'll have one for the south
the south uh level dot create and as you
can imagine this will basically have i
should copy and paste this
x block uh it which is normal and z
block will obviously have one added to
it
plus one all right awesome so let's
start with uh let's actually start with
randomly generating it so
if um if if we if a solid render gets
called
so if block.solid is equal
is equal to true um
let's say that if the east
solid solid is uh is not true
then let's render wall so
x block and i've already worked this out
beforehand because it would have taken a
while to actually place these blocks
properly
um x block x block plus one so both the
max plus
ah x block plus one uh z block
and z block plus one and obviously
for the so this is filling out the first
four obviously for height we'll just put
that at zero
for now all right
now i'm going to copy and paste
this if statement once more because i'm
not going to
completely do it except this time as you
can imagine i'm going to change it to
south
and uh we'll have to play around with
this a bit and all i'm going to do
basically is
uh add one here and take
one away from well
is it the second one all right so i've
sort of switched these two around
um okay let's go back to our
and bracket of this if statement and go
else not ls
else if
it is now equal to true
so basically what we've done we've said
that if blocked solid let's do that but
if
if it's yeah then each dot solid
dot solid um
is that a comma because i meant a dot
okay cool um
then let's render wall
x block plus one this will all make
sense by the way when we actually
uh deal with it um plus one
and then z block and then zero and
exactly the same thing for the south
side
all right and um but let's change the
south
south and again we're gonna
accept actually no this time not again
let's just get rid of this one and put
it
up to here
all right cool that uh that should
pretty much done actually um
yeah let's run it and see what we get
all right so guys as you can see we have
a basic level right here
now uh a few problems
there's actually two problems with this
but the first one is
clipping is weird um
wow look at that but uh but the second
problem is that it appears that walls
are rendering in front of walls they
shouldn't be rendering in front of
so clearly these are behind those ones
but for some reason they're not
rendering like they're behind those ones
they're rendering like they're in front
of those ones
and the other problem we have is um
the other problem we have is clipping
all right
quick diagnostic uh like lecture
to you guys more water for me
quick diagnostic lecture if you've got a
problem like this
and you know what it's what it's it what
like what's causing it it helps to
basically know how graphics work
this is clearly clearly an issue with
clipping
now that's something that you need to
understand
um when you have random graphic
artifacts on the screen it's probably
like
that look like this it's probably
something to do with clipping
now having that like in mind
we can check out the code for the
clipping so from basically from clip
all of this stuff is the code for
clipping and we can basically use that
to diagnose to say that okay well we
know it's a problem with clipping
and this is where we've handled clipping
so clearly we've done something wrong
somewhere here all right so now i'm
going to go ahead
and try and figure out the problem so
right okay so uh
it seems all right
we've got a slight problem here actually
i i did notice that before
um this should be four because we've
already done three that obviously won't
fix our problem but it doesn't help to
check
yep you can see that we're still getting
stuff in front of us um let's try this
over here
now what i would do if i were you is i'd
compare this code to the
website or whatever to my code to
whatever and make sure it's clearly
correct
and just by looking at it i can say that
it is correct
because this is you know the cohen's
other subtle end
uh um what we call it
the clipping algorithm um
colin sullivan uh clipping algorithm and
it seems okay
so the next step to say is that you know
that this code is right
then let's say okay well there are
variables in this code are they right
and uh you can take a look at it and you
can say
and you can basically say alright well
what's right and what's wrong
so looking at this
seems that everything is right
okay you can let's check let's check out
a few a few of these things so we
we're using these variables and we can
say that they're being modified
somewhere and clipping should come
before modification of variables
so we can see that they're being called
here which is fine but for some reason
they're being modified
here and that code is happening before
clipping
and that could be causing the error so
what i'm going to do is i'm going to cut
this code
out and i'm actually going to put it
basically directly directly under
clipping so basically right
here make sure they're before those
let's hit ctrl s and
oh check that out we've fixed it
just like that and now
you can see guys that we've got
basically a randomly generated level
and i'll show you guys a few different
things later but
first i want to fix this problem here
where um
it seems that okay actually before i go
into that it looks like
we've got two units because we did go
plus one
over here instead of plus 0.5 um
so what we'll do is we'll actually just
permanently set it to plus one we could
change this to 0.5 obviously because
these are doubles
but let's just go ahead and say okay
well x left let's divide that by two
and right let's divide that by two
and we'll have to also divide this by
two
and this by two so we've halved
everything so
in in other words we're changing the
ones to 0.5
so let's check it out and now we should
have
a bunch of uh you can say
things and they get randomly generated
let's let's try out
increasing the size to like 10 and that
should give us a much
larger uh sort of area to play around
with it and you can see that now they're
squares and uh actually you can see that
now
when i go really close the texture
doesn't distort when i rotate like it
used to
so that must have been a problem with
claiming obviously but a problem with
with this code being before clipping so
yeah
the order of code matters greatly
obviously and i've
you know i've shown you guys that before
with like render distance but if i put
render distance like after this well not
really after this but before this
it's sort of well it yeah clearly
something's different there
um but yeah all right um
so yeah so you can see that does that's
awesome all right so we've got this
other problem and
it sort of seems to me and this is like
it's kind of like x-ray mode check that
out how cool is that
it's pretty cool um and it's kind of
confusing us because
it's not it's showing blocks that are
behind blocks even though it shouldn't
be because they're behind it
so it's as if these blocks aren't solid
so
we need to fix that and the way we can
fix it is uh
it's actually not hard to fix all right
we'll make
here's what we'll do we'll make a
variable
in render 3d let's just close this for a
minute uh
and we'll just make another we've got z
buffer let's just
duplicate that and call it z buffer wall
so z buffer wall will deal with
our actual um our wall stuff
and we don't need to make it a we just
we'll make it a new double
and we'll just put width in it
all right so now let's um
we'll actually we'll put it right at the
top of floor let's just say that four in
x
equals zero as long as x is less than
with
uh x plus plus and let's just set it
equal to zero
so that it won't render
what's the problem with this do we
make it in you oh hang on
make sure you put x in here all right
cool
um all right um
all right um the other thing we need to
do
is let's come down here
to our not that far to our render
wall thing um and
right when we actually start rendering
the walls so into for loops
um let's just um
let's just make a well actually we'll
make a double
i'll call it zed wall set that equal to
text
one plus i'm gonna just set it equal to
this
actually
and the reason is that i'm going to have
to use that code later i don't want to
have to retype it so
let's just divide that by said
wall right cool
um and
i'll do that all the uh next to just say
and
we can probably just do it right here if
uh if our z buffer wall
x uh is greater than our zed wall
so greater than that then we'll uh
we'll continue definitely
um and we want to set it equal
to z wall
so let's check it out now
all right awesome you can see that now
we can't see
other other blocks behind blocks which
is awesome now there's a slight problem
though because it sort of chops them off
you can see that it chops them off all
right that's a bit of a problem
so your first homework for
this week is to try and fix it all right
i'll show you guys how to fix that next
week
but uh i want you guys to have a go at
it and again whoever solves it will get
a shout out
so that's your award i guess um
uh to solving this uh this problem
for doing your homework um and but the
other otherwise we seem awesome
so we've got this awesome like world to
play around with that's
cool all right um yeah so now let's play
around with the actual random
world generator uh wall generator
actually it's a wall
generator let's just increase the size
to like 20 or something
you can actually get like a proper wall
and if you hit spacebar and you can sort
of see like
the uh you can't really see the world
though because again it's
getting clipped sort of by the z buffer
wall but uh let's play around with this
you can see that it's like a maze
and the only problem at the moment is
that
uh it's sort of see if we can find a way
around this
can't really um
all right anyway you can see that
this isn't really a problem but at the
moment we can see above like this thing
so just for the just clearly for testing
purposes i want to copy all this code
um in fact no i'm not
i am not going to copy all the code i
think i'll just
copy let me think for a minute
yeah i'll grab all the code
and let me just control say that control
v that and all i'll do here is
we can see by height that that's what
the height now remember we want the same
like we wanted to be in the same
position so let's just change
all these the last parameter to uh to
0.5
because that is our height and if we
run this then we should get uh yeah all
right cool
so we've actually got like a nice maze
now obviously we don't have collisions
so we can go through walls
but um you can see that through this you
can play around with this and it's
completely randomly generated so every
time you launch it
it will be different um unless you
launch it enough times in which case it
won't be different
um i don't know how many times you have
to launch it i might i don't know
maybe someone can tell me the amount of
possibilities because i'm well i'm tired
i'm not gonna work it out i might work
it out after i start
actually uh after i finish recording but
uh yeah all right so you can see that
every time i launch it let's just launch
it here
there's a wall environment launched
again it's different
it's different it's different
i've launched a lot of them haven't i
alright
it's using a lot of resources but yeah
you can see that every time i launch it
it's different
all right so like every time
i launch the game there's a different
world for me
to explore so yeah so that's the random
world generator
and i hope you guys enjoyed this
tutorial um
hit the like button let's get to 200
likes again we've done it once let's do
it again we actually
had a bit of trouble getting to it we
took like five days to get to it which
is which is cool because um
all the other times i said you know
let's get like 100 likes we usually hit
them within like 12 hours of me
releasing the video so uh
it was nice it was kind of a challenge
so let's let's do it again let's hit up
200 likes hit the like button
and um i personally don't know what to
do next episode oh
okay next episode i think what we'll do
is we'll handle collisions so that you
guys can't walk through walls so we'll
really make the walls solid um yeah i
think that's probably what we'll do
yeah so you can see that there is an end
to this and again if we just increase
the size to like
i don't know 50 or something
then you can see that it becomes even
bigger if we sprint
like it's pretty big
and let's also actually go into level
and increase this
where's our level no not level game
and increase this like i don't know 80.
then let's render it let's run it
and yeah you can see that it's even
bigger now check that out
so yeah there's like a huge randomly
generated world which is awesome because
look it looks awesome
doesn't it and we can see 360 degrees
around cubes
around these things all right so that uh
that's it all right
now one more thing actually before i go
i want to just mention one more thing
this is a
45 minute tutorial so far but uh anyway
uh one more thing i wanted to mention
was um
someone said you know will i sort of
teach you guys how to do like a
color-coded like
level generator and i know what you mean
that's like if you put like a pixel of
red it'll
put like a specific wall there or
whatever like notch did
uh with his games um yeah we'll probably
do it that way because
that's actually that type of level
design there's actually a class in java
called robot
i'm sure you guys know of it there's
something called create screen capture
and there's also something called
like get pixel color it returns the
color of a pixel at the given screen
coordinates so
you could load you could basically use
this stuff to load
a um to load like a
an image file and it will read the color
of the pixel and you can say that if the
color
equals uh blah blah and there's also a
java class
called uh color let me just find it
color um
yeah you know you can say that if if
color equals blah blah blah or whatever
if that pixel using that with the robot
class if that
pixel color is is this color let's place
this block or let's execute this
this amount this code and that's
actually a huge way of making levels
that's a huge method of level design for
you know for minute full sort of like
low low end
3d games and pretty much all 2d games so
we'll
we'll definitely be doing it that way if
i was making like a
huge game in it like in lw jgl and
everything with opengl
then i would probably not obviously not
use that as level design
i would probably just um actually
construct the level in 3d studio max or
something
and import that as a 3d model and handle
the level like that and handle collision
and stuff like that um that's that's a
lot harder to do
so that's probably the way we'll
actually do it but anyway guys um
i will see you guys later and uh
yeah it's getting late and i'm i
apologize for this episode okay i'm
really tired but i'm sure that
i've given you guys uh something cool to
play with
so yeah so yeah so definitely check out
um
check out you know playing around with
it if i go to level and if we increase
this
this to like 10 then um you'll see that
we actually get
uh the blocks become a lot more rare so
you can see that
there's a huge spec there's huge spaces
now and again if i set it to like two or
something then
you'll be able to see that uh there's
basically a block everywhere
and it's not really anywhere i can i can
be without
being surrounded by blocks so yeah and
again 20 or whatever will
have basically no blocks so yeah you can
play with that and uh you could even do
something like
if um greater than
10 then again that's basically the same
thing as saying um
that is equal to zero well
i already have insert um and that is
like
two but anyway i want to leave it as it
is at the moment play around with
with the with the level slash wall
generator that we made
and uh yeah and that's pretty much it
guys i will uh
hit the like button let's get it 200
likes and i will see you guys later
bye